$11.99 in king richard the lionheart is
dead Richard left no heirs and so his
dominions all of this was to be
inherited by either his brother John who
Richard her chosen or by his nephew
Arthur of brittany arthur began a
rebellion but nothing came of it and
john managed to get the french king to
accept his territorial claims after
becoming King John had his first
marriage annulled and instead married
Isabella of angel' M in 1202 fighting
resumed between the kings of England and
France because by this point they were
both getting pretty good at it John
attempted to mount a defense of his
lands but due to financial constraint
and the fact that he often insulted his
nobility his ability to do so was
lacking by the end of 1204 philippe
augustus had conquered both Normandy and
Anjou whereas Brittany had broken away
from Anne ship in orbit on its own thus
within five years of John coming to the
throne only Aquitaine remained of his
inheritance naturally many of the
remaining Nobles in England were very
unhappy that they had just lost some of
their Continental lands the peasantry of
England also found themselves upset when
John levied extremely heavy taxes to pay
for an attempted reconquest so by 1205
John was dishonored and disliked by his
Nobles but at least he still had good
relations with the church right nope the
main issue between John and the church
occurred during the election of the
Archbishop of Canterbury in 1205 John
wanted a friend and a lo of his to
become the new archbishop whereas the
clerics at Canterbury Cathedral did not
the Pope Innocent the third was appealed
to in his answer was that they were in
fact both wrong and the Pope instead
consecrated a man called Stephen Langton
John was furious about this and so
banned lankton from entering England and
seized Canterbury's assets and revenues
many clergymen saw this as a step too
far and when they complained to John he
essentially declared them traitors and
seized their property as well
the Pope attempted to convince the king
to agree to Langdon's appointment but
the king still refused and so in 1208
the Pope ordered that church services in
England were to be halted which they
were for six years in 1209 the Pope went
further and excommunicated John as well
12:09 was an eventful year for John and
England's is before his excommunication
he invaded Scotland fearing that its
King King William the lion was planning
on forging an alliance with France the
invasion went well and William agree to
pay John and would stop claiming
Northumbria so there was one success at
least this year also saw the
establishment of another Center of
Education at Cambridge thus the two
major centers of learning in England had
been founded both of which would
dominate English intellectual and
political life for centuries to come in
1210 the barons of Ireland revolted and
John crossed the sea and crushed them
shortly
of course it was brony rebellion which
would ultimately define John's brain and
so unsurprisingly this would not be the
last it's important to note the bearings
have a justification to revolt against
John because he had been excommunicated
technically lords owed no allegiance to
their superiors who lived outside of the
boundaries of the Christian faith in
practice the reasons for revolts weren't
so theological in 1212 John forged a
series of alliances against King
Philippe to prepare for an invasion of
France the most notable ally being the
Count of Flanders Philippe made the
first move and attacked Flanders and was
himself preparing to invade England
John's barons weren't very supportive
and only due to a pre-emptive English
attack didn't invasion not occur by this
time John had realised that he needed
his barons onside who would the
convenient excuse of excommunication to
refuse his service in 1213 he and Pope
Innocent came to an agreement the king
would repay the church for everything he
took and importantly it was decided that
John held England as a papal fief what
this meant is that technically England
belonged to the Pope and John simply
ruled over it as the Pope is appointed
keeper the next year John had secured
more alliances in his war with France
the most notable being the Holy Roman
Emperor Otto the fourth the decisive
battle was in July the 27th the Battle
of the boovie
which was a decisive French victory this
battle forever ruined John's chances of
recovering his northern French
territories as well as earning him the
nickname John Lackland Jude mostly to
his lack of land Phillipe Augustus was
now the undisputed ruler of these
territories marking an important turning
point in the rise of France
John's problems went from bad to worse
upon his return to England in 1215 John
Snow was revolted against him plunging
England into chaos the rebellious Nobu's
approach was not to replace the king but
to force reforms the rebels were led by
Robert Fitzwater who he made 1215 March
what the rebels had made the army of God
into London John knew this wasn't going
to end well and so whilst Archbishop
Langton to organize peace talks what
happened at these talks is one of the
most famous and important events in
English history the signing of the Magna
Carta at Runnymede which is here Magna
Carta which is Latin for Great Charter
sought to restrict John's powers over
the dispensing of justice which John had
up until that point mostly used to make
money it's also importantly stated that
if John was to abandon his promises
within Magna Carta his barons could use
force against him John did sign the
Magna Carta but make no mistake he had
no intention of abiding by it and
quickly asked the Pope who was
technically John's Lord to annul the
agreement which the Pope did John's
parents were not too happy about this
and so on
the Baron's knew that John would never
accept their demands and so they invited
a new claimant to the throne whom they
could rally behind this man was Louie
the son and heir of the French King
Philippe Augustus Louie arrived in
England in May 1216 within a few months
had taken all of this territory little
more happened to her John died in
October of the same year and for many of
the rebellious barons the reason for the
war had died with the King John had a
young son Henry who many of the
rebellious barons flocked to the reason
for this was that Henry at this point
was only nine years old and thus was
much less of a threat to noble interest
than Louis could be Henry was crowned
King Henry the third at Gloucester but
he was too young to govern and so the
respected nobleman William Marshall
acted as his Regent being Regent meant
that Marshall would act with the Kings
Authority until the king was old enough
to do so himself
Marshalls first act would be to reissue
Magna Carta in Henry's name to assure
the other Nobles that their rights would
be upheld
Louis was of course not going to give up
his claim to England and so the war
carried on the war was not going in
Henry's favor until 1217 when Willy
Marshall marched on Lincoln in an
all-or-nothing battle the Battle of
Lincoln saw many of Louie's French
nobleman killed Robert fitzwater was
captured and afterwards the town was
thoroughly looted as a result Menino was
defected from Louis to Henry and after a
few more battles Henry's throne was
secured and Louis renounced his claim
Henry's early reign was not without its
problems many nobles had pledged their
loyalty but weren't so keen on actually
providing it some had built castles
illegally during the rebellion and
refused to abandon and demolished them
to reassure Henry's Authority the Pope
allowed him to be coronated again this
time in London and most of his Lords
pledged allegiance and a pain of
excommunication some still refuse to
pledge their loyalty and so at the help
of his just akia hubert de burgh henry
crushed them in 1224 lui now King Louie
the eighth for France invaded Henry's
French territories and quickly seized
part two of most of Gascony the nobles
agreed to help fund an army to reinforce
Gascony on the condition the Magna Carta
was reissued again which it was in 1225
this time Magna Carta was issued
willingly by a king who agreed to be
bound by the laws and the advice of his
know was a significant stepping stone in
the history of the English monarchy in
1226 Louie the eighth for France died
and the throne passed to his son whose
name you'll never guess unless you also
guess Louis this new king was only 12
and so his position was weak many of the
nobles in Normandy Anjou and Britain he
asked for Henry to invade and reclaim
his inheritance in 1227 the Regency
ended and Henry began his personal rule
three years later he landed in Paris
me with the large English army he would
remain in France until 1234 and would
leave having achieved nothing a great
cost
when Henry left for France he had placed
Hubert de baron charge Hubert was not
particularly popular in the faction
which opposed him rally behind a man who
pitted the rush in 1231 after his return
to England Peter wrote to Henry claiming
that Hubert was corrupt and so Henry had
Hubert arrested and Peter was made to
stickier Peter almost immediately began
seizing his opponents land which angered
a certain Richard Marshall the son of
William who complained that the king was
neglecting his promises from Magna Carta
naturally there would only be one
outcome of this disagreement civil war
in the end Henry agreed to remove Peter
and wood from then onwards rule on his
own Henry was so keen for peace because
he was worried that during the Civil War
Louis would invade and conquer Brittany
which he did anyway so Henry believed
that his predecessors mostly his father
had allowed royal authority and dignity
to be eroded and he sought to restore it
in 1236 Henry married Eleanor of
Provence in order to forge an alliance
in the South of France
three years later Eleanor gave birth to
a son Edward named after Edward the
Confessor who Henry revered is the
paragon of English kingship so Henry
made sure to look after his wife's
family and eventually they were invited
over and some of them are giving
important positions an example being
Ellen his uncle Boniface he was made
Archbishop of Canterbury all of this
preferential treatment for people who
weren't the English nobility was
upsetting for the English nobility since
they felt these rewards were theirs by
rights
needless to say Henry was well on his
way to annoying his barons again so in
1241 Henry stepfather rebelled against
the French King and called for Henry to
land with an army to assist which Henry
did eventually Henry slow response meant
that the rebellion collapsed and during
the campaign there Henry's army was
soundly defeated at the Battle of tiberg
as a result of this Henry's French
relatives by marriage ended up leaving
France and coming to England in 1247
these relatives were granted numerous
lands which further annoyed the English
nobility by 1258 Henry was extremely
unpopular he had financially ruined the
kingdom the most notable event occurring
in 1252 when the Pope offered Henry
Sicily providing he paid off the Pope's
debt which he agreed to without
consulting his Lords furthermore Henry
also travelled to Paris where he agreed
to renounce his claims to his lost
territories the anger of his noble was
culminated in rebellion again led by
Simon de Montfort the rebels demanded
Henry abandon his personal rule and
allow the nobles to control the
government and Institute reforms
these reforms are summed up in the
provisions of ox
which limited the powers at the king in
the major Nobles but most importantly
set up an elected group of barons who
would run the kingdom these form of
government broke down after Henry had
asked for the Pope's help in denouncing
it in 1263 the second barons war broke
out long story short the war waged for
four years Henry and his son Edward were
captured at the Battle of Lewes Edward
eventually escaped and later won a
victory at the Battle of Evesham which
saw de Montfort killed by 1267 the
Barons had surrendered and the war was
over leaving a now unwell Henry to
rebuild Prince Edward was given great to
say over the running of the kingdom
until he went on a crusade in 1270 Henry
died in 1272 when Edward was declared
king and upon his return to England he
was crowned king yet with the first
Edward however is better known either as
Edward Longshanks or more famously as
malleus Scott Horan the hammer of the
Scots I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching there are
some book recommendations in the
description if you'd like to know more
you